in today's video we're going to be
focusing on whether Bitcoin is ready for
its parabolic phase in the cycle because
we have two phases left it's the post
Haring reaccumulation period which we're
in currently and the post Haring
parabolic upside that we are going to be
preparing for through this consolidation
so subscribe to the channel for more
videos like this in the future let's
dive into today's video and talk more
about this in a lot of detail so Bitcoin
has been consolidating at these highs
this is a typical accumulation range
that you see develop in the post harving
period we've seen this multiple times in
the past here in 2020 for example we saw
two micro reaccumulation ranges develop
as a larger macro reaccumulation range
and we saw this price action break out
from this range 160 days after the
harving so this is essentially Where The
Red Square comes into play essentially
accounting for history repeating itself
with a 150 to 160 day breakout period
and in 2016 we also saw
150 days or so in fact this should be
right over here the red should go on to
here in fact so that would be
150 160
days but the only difference here was
that we actually broke out pulled back
and retested the top of this range and
then rallied towards the upside we
didn't really see that in 2020 we just
rallied without looking back but if we
look at Price action and the current few
months that we've seen or actually the
current several weeks that we've seen
here we're already at the Range High
Resistance and what we've seen in 2020
at this point in the cycle was also
price trying to break out and revisit
this Range High and in fact we broke out
even higher to develop the new Range
High right over here before for
rejecting so that's quite interesting to
see that we're we're seeing 2020 be
quite close to 2024 in the sense that we
are seeing a breakout or we've seen a
breakout over the past 2 weeks and now
we're at that resistance but when we
consider 2016 for example and the 30 40
days after the harving 2016 was really
lagging behind in that respect so
according to 2016 2024 is very much
ahead of schedule because in 2016 we
were just hovering at the range low
slightly starting to begin the rally and
then only a few weeks later we Revisited
the Range High here so 2016 is lagging
behind the 2024 price performance and
the 2024 price performance is pretty
much in line with what we what we saw at
this same point in the cycle in 2020
that's very interesting to see because
we've been seeing 2016 really closely
mimic or at least 2024 closely mimic
2016 we were seeing that loads of
Tendencies were repeating for example
the danger zone after the having 2024
repeated 2016 in that respect of course
the downside Wick wasn't as long but
then we saw Trend following for a brief
amount of time and then 2024 started to
separate itself from 2016 and in fact
2024 is starting to resemble more 2020
at this point in the cycle so it's quite
interesting to see how 2024 is going to
be a hybrid of 2026 and 2024 at this
moment in the cycle but if we look at
for example this reaccumulation range we
always see a reaccumulation range around
the post Haring period that remains to
be the case 2016 as well but generally
speaking 2024 has been seeing multiple
reaccumulation ranges develop over the
course of the cycle which is very 2016
like so we do see lots of cross
similarities between 2016 and and 2024
the reaccumulation ranges here are very
similar to what we're seeing in 2024 and
the post harving danger zone is very
similar to what we saw in 2016 but there
are elements that were now resembling
2020 more in fact but when it comes to
altcoins this is a pathway that I spoke
about in mid-February that we're really
following quite nicely here we rebounded
from this blue level rallied to the red
region rejected here after brief upside
deviation back at the $250 billion level
as a support and now we're recovering
from here and continued upside from here
should get us to this light blue circle
over time
I don't know how much time that will
take whether we're going to achieve this
in this quarter hype cycle or in
Q3 but the thing here is that this
upside altcoin market cap is preparing
itself for that sort of upside and this
ties in with the Q the Q2 quarter 2
altcoin hype cycle that we're starting
to see bottoming out here in the altcoin
market we've definitely seen downside
Wicks and just construction of a base at
this region here just above the $250
billion level so we're seeing bottoming
out structures form in the altcoin
market cap also in many different
altcoins so it does make sense that this
is going to be the bottoming out period
for altcoins in general how long is it
going to last that Still Remains to be
seen this is now altcoins being on the
cusp of a new quarter 2 hype cycle and
we've seen phenomenal performance from
the q1 hype cycle we saw fantastic
upside late in 2023 from the Q4 altcoin
hype cycle could we still see that
phenomenal upside once again in this Q2
Alin hype cycle as we go into the thick
of summer because the Q2 hype cycle is
going to occur regardless but we just
don't know know how strong or how weak
that Q2 hyp cycle is going to be You
could argue that if this is going to be
a weak Q2 hyp cycle then maybe Q3 or Q4
will be even stronger as a result really
depends on how we perform here but
everything is aligning perfectly in
terms of timing we are currently at the
bottom of this lowest hype region which
is also the point of Maximum Financial
opportunity and then later near the end
of the quarter we're going to get to a
point where allcoins are going to
materialize their rallies mature in
their uptrends and then reach a ceiling
that they won't really be able to break
as the hype has really just translated
into price action and valuation
increases and this is where that point
of Maximum Financial Risk is before
deflation in the valuations across the
entire Market really predominantly
altcoin suffering the most but also
Bitcoin would probably see a pullback at
this time as well or at the very least a
re accumulation period once again so the
stars are aligning here timing wise but
also altcoin Mark kept building out that
base and preparing to follow through on
this altcoin rally but the last thing I
just want to mention here is that
history is suggesting to us that we
could be consolidating here for a few
more months because 160 days after the
harving means that September would be a
breakout for Bitcoin so really that does
translate into further consolidation for
a few months if history is going to
repeat itself and history is suggesting
that we won't break this Range High
Resistance anytime soon at the moment
this 70-day 75 day consolidation period
is reducing the rate of acceleration
that we're seeing in the cycle when we
saw this old water High get reached in
mid-march the rate of acceleration was
260 days now that we're seeing a 75 day
reaccumulation
period that has that rate of
acceleration has reduced to
approximately 180 days it would be
fantastic to continue to see this
reduction in the rate of acceleration
through additional reaccumulation and
consolidation at these highs will we get
it that remains to be seen history is
suggesting that we should get that sort
of extended consolidation but we are
just one weekly close away above the
Range High Resistance to enter a
parabolic rally weekly close like here
you can see that that's exactly what's
needed to break out from here weekly
close right over here as well retest
rally towards the upside and then we get
a second retest which isn't something
that we get often in a post Haring
reaccumulation range breakout sometimes
we just rally and never look back so
history is suggesting additional
consolidation but if we get a weekly
close that won't matter because history
essentially Bitcoin would go against the
grain of History if we get that Weekly
close above the Range High re
accumulation range but at the moment
we're forming a lower high relative to
these highs so this is a lower high
already in the making history is
suggesting we'll move
sideways and if we continue to move
sideways maybe this is going to
facilitate some of those altcoin rallies
and the altcoin market cap to increase
in its General valuation altcoins in the
market wide to continue increasing in
their prices and really the stars are
aligning the stages set are we going to
see that are we going to see the Q2
altcoin hype cycle really materialized
and see altcoin start rallying across
the board thank you so much for watching
subscribe to the channel for more videos
like this in the future like this video
if you enjoy content like this going for
D capital and I'll speak to you in the
next one speak to you soon